we prescribe medications that cause be
mature death read the package inserts
it's right there the ketogenic diet
helps people lose weight get rid of
their diabetes or improve their insulin
sensitivity lower their risk for
cardiovascular disease helps them get
off of medications helps them start
functioning in life again I really don't
give a [ __ ] if their LDL goes up a
little I just don't anybody who is going
to get worked up about their LDL going
up a little bit in the context of all of
that other stuff is an absolute positive
idiot and they are inhumane they are
inhumane that they would let people
suffer and writhe in mental pain and be
disabled by their illness and not offer
them an effective treatment that is just
inhumane
[Music]
Dr Chris Palmer welcome to my podcast
thank you Michaela Peterson for having
me this is great I am so excited to be
talking to somebody from Harvard who's
discussing diet as a treatment for
depression this is crazy I've been
waiting for this to happen for a while
well wait no wait no longer I am here
okay amazing yours I have followed your
story for several years and uh your
story is a perfect representation of the
science that I have been pursuing
because I've been trying to explain the
science
of stories like yours and other peoples
so that we can get the mental health
field to take this seriously amazing
okay fantastic well for anyone who isn't
familiar with you although I've seen you
on a ton of podcasts recently can you
describe a bit about who you are and
what you do so I'm Chris Palmer I have
been a psychiatrist at McLean Hospital
in Harvard Medical School for over 27
years now
uh my my day job is actually
um I am the director of the Department
of postgraduate and continuing education
uh so I oversee uh educational programs
for McLean Hospital in Harvard
um and I've been doing that for over 20
years
I have over 15 years of experience as a
neuroscience researcher working in the
fields of addiction and sleep uh and
I've always had a private practice of uh
um Psychiatry so I tend to treat
treatment resistant patients a wide
variety of disorders
um schizophrenia bipolar chronic
depression personality disorders anxiety
disorders substance use disorders but
the unifying theme of the patients that
I work with are that they have treatment
resistant disorders which means they
have already been to at least five or
six different psychiatrist therapists
other people they've usually been on
dozens of meds they've
tried Psychotherapy for years or decades
they've sometimes had ECT or TMS already
and then they come to me and was like
can you do anything for me
uh and the reason I'm on your podcast
the reason I have a book
because
I've been really interested in the role
of diets in particular low carbohydrate
and ketogenic diets in the treatment of
mental disorders but serious mental
disorders is really my focus I can
definitely help people with mild
depression anxiety or burnout but I'm
treating patients with schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder people who are
chronically disabled public
hallucinations to Illusions and uh
finding success and restoring their
health getting them off all meds and
many of them living happily ever after
yay for that that's great
um okay I've got a question just about
that for people it's kind of specific
but for people who you see that are
suffering from hallucinations do you are
they ever not medicated and still
suffering from hallucinations
or are they always medicated and
suffering from hallucinations so you
know right
you know at this point I have lots of
people who are non-medicate who used to
suffer from hallucinations
they are off all meds and they are now
symptom-free
um as a rule of thumb over my career
I've seen a wide range so I see people
when they first get diagnosed
no medications something happens out in
the real world to them
and they developed their first psychotic
episode
they uh they start having hallucinations
delusions often in the context of some
mood symptoms as well whether it's a
manic episode or a depressed episode
um and then they usually get brought
into an emergency room police get called
something happens uh and then they
usually end up in the hospital I've done
hospital inpatient work for for years
uh and in that context I would see them
either in the emergency room and maybe
even be the first person to prescribe
medications or I would be their
inpatient psychiatrist and taking care
of them or I would become their
outpatient psychiatrist and start
treating them you know somebody else
treated them in the hospital and then I
kind of take over as their outpatient
psychiatrists so I've seen a whole range
interesting that sounds like a stressful
job
it can be
um
I'm actually pretty passionate about
this work and helping people
and uh trying to get them all the way
better and uh
so
hey
it can be stressful I mean I've
definitely
especially when our treatments don't
work for people
and that occurs a lot more often than
most people realize certainly not you
but I think you get it
yeah yeah a lot of people don't get it
they think that our treatments are
supposed to work and and then I have
patients coming in to me in tears or
angry yelling at me whatever like why
isn't this working you get you're giving
me pill after pill and none of them are
working and they're giving me side
effects or they're making me gain weight
or they're they make me feel like a
zombie this isn't working do something
you're supposed to be the expert why
aren't you doing something I have
families parents of these bright
children who were like Stellar college
students their lives are decimated and
just disintegrating in front of
everyone's eyes and the parents are
looking at me like what are you doing
why aren't you getting my son or
daughter better like what are you doing
and I have to be the one to like look
them in the eye and say
we don't know or the the this is the
best we've got that's where I was I'm in
a very different place now and hopefully
we'll get get to talk about all that but
that's where I was for over 20 years so
um how do I want to start this maybe
let's start with could you could you
describe what a ketogenic diet is for
anyone who isn't familiar with it so a
ketogenic diet you know most people know
it as a trendy weight loss diet and uh
my interest in it is really more is an
epilepsy treatment so it turns out the
ketogenic diet
um at least one version of it was
developed a hundred years ago
specifically by a physician for one and
only one purpose it was actually
developed to stop seizures
um and it was developed to mimic the
fasting State because the doctors at
that time knew that fasting or at least
had reason to believe that fasting can
stop seizures
the problem with fasting is that if you
fast for too long you starve to death
and that's not a very good treatment
so
um so Dr Russell Wilder invented the
ketogenic diet with the purpose of
trying to trick the body into thinking
that it was fasting when it really
wasn't
but providing enough nutrition so that
the person was not starving and even so
that young children could grow and
thrive on a ketogenic diet but he wanted
to see if it could stop seizures and lo
and behold it worked and uh for a while
it was actually the Mainstay treatment
for epilepsy in the 1920s and 30s it was
one of the Mainstay treatments for
epilepsy and it stopped seizures and
about 50 of people with epilepsy
it reduced seizure frequency in another
35 so about 85 percent pretty good
response rate
um and then there were about 15 percent
of people for whom it did not seem to
work for whatever reason
um
and it fell out of favor when we got all
these medications and but then it got it
came back
um and it's widely used as an epilepsy
treatment
the reason that was so critical to me as
a psychiatrist is we use epilepsy
treatments in Psychiatry all the time
tons of pills that we prescribe are
actually epilepsy treatments
and
um a lot of them are names people know
Valium Klonopin Xanax and others things
with azepines all of those are seizure
treatments
um and so
you know I the short version
is that I ended up
and trying to help one of my patients
because of affective disorder lose
weight
and uh I had no thought that it would do
anything for his psychiatric symptoms
but he went on a ketogenic diet
within a couple weeks started getting an
antidepressant effect
within about two months got a powerful
antipsychotic effect hallucinations were
melting away delusions were melting away
and that sent me I don't know I sent my
whole career on the New Path it gives me
goosebumps
that's so cool okay that is so cool it's
so exciting
hearing about this just out there
um and having medical professionals use
it as a form of treatment I think
in my case in my dad's case
in my case in particular I think when he
went on antidepressants it actually
helped him
um but I went on antidepressants and it
helped me for like a year
and then it just didn't really help like
it numbed me but it didn't really help
and I just got worse and worse and worse
and worse and worse
and I've been unbelievably frustrated
with the medical system because like I I
never went into an office and said you
were supposed to help me this is your
fault but
um but I probably thought that
so it's really exciting to see something
that and it's funny we've been using the
ketogenic diet you know like you said
for 100 years and it kind of fell out of
favor because there was a pill which is
a lot easier than adhering to a diet
have you had a difficult time getting
your patients to adhere to a diet
particularly when they're very ill for
some patients absolutely and and I
definitely have patients who
either didn't even want to try it
and or they tried it for a few days or
something and they just couldn't do it
um
and you know I didn't have the Intensive
resources that some of them I think need
in order to be able to do the diet you
can't admit them to any program where
they will administer the diet right now
for the most part I didn't even have you
know I now have dietitians that work
with me but you know over over the years
you know for a long time I didn't even
have dietitians or anybody else who
would support it was just me as a solo
practitioner recommending these
treatments however
I have so yes it does not not everybody
can do the diet
but I have patients with chronic
schizophrenia and bipolar disorder
people who are actively hallucinating
delusional
one woman was stuck in a chair
staring at the wall all day every day
she was like locked in
and could not function
she's on massive doses of psychiatric
meds she was wetting her pants because
she was so overdosed on psychiatric meds
and
she and her boyfriend at the time kind
of came to me again in one of these
angry States like you've got to do
something like she she can't function
she's overwhelmed with hallucinations
and delusions you have to do something
and
she had been my patient for many many
years she had already tried everything
under the sun she'd been on over 30
medications she'd been in and out of
hospitals in residential treatment
programs she had already had
electroconvulsive therapy I think twice
that point
so had done
every standard treatment
and when they kind of came to me in this
angry State I was like you know what you
guys have to do the ketogenic diet
um and I was saying this to the
boyfriend too like you've got to help
her do this diet I mean obviously she is
severely impaired she really belonged in
a hospital is where she belonged if we
could get a hospital to deliver
appropriate care but they would have
simply put her on more and more
medicines
um and essentially made her comatose
uh and
at the end of the day she was able to do
the diet
took about three months for you know a
couple weeks for her to come out of this
kind of almost catatonic state where she
was just staring at the wall all day
took several months about three months
for the hallucinations and delusions to
start going away
she is now
a completely new person
she went to the metabolic Health Summit
with me on stage and told her story she
is now a graduate student getting the
top grades in her class
she is now engaged she actually that
boyfriend actually was trouble so she
got rid of him yeah
five new fiance like things are
dramatically better for her
she is not a hundred percent recovered
because we're still trying to get her
off all the meds that she had been on
and we continue to make progress
I know you know it is not an easy
process to get off meds it can be a
disaster and it can be dangerous people
can get suicidal they can get more
psychotic all sorts of things
but um but we're we're getting there and
she's functioning and she is developing
a new life Wow
that's an incredible story
congratulations thank you well
congratulations go to her because she's
the one who's doing it she's the one
who's recovering and uh I am just glad
that I could
help her wow
that's great
that's great
um so you said at least for this patient
I would say Let me let me see how to
formulate this question
um well how long does it take on average
for somebody to start recovering from
say psychotic or depressive symptoms on
the ketogenic diet
you know for
for a lot of people I start to notice
antidepressant effects usually within
the first two weeks
um
it can be variable and different people
have different responses especially
based on the different meds that they
might be taking so I mean some people
can be on one or two meds other people
can be on 14 meds
those meds are affecting them in
profoundly different ways and some of
those mids are actually interfering with
the effects of the ketogenic diet or you
know preventing preventing ketosis so it
can make it harder to do the diet
um
usually for the antipsychotic effects
they take longer
um most of my patients I begin to see an
antipsychotic effect usually around the
six to eight week Mark
um and for some people it can be three
to four months like that woman I just
described it it really was three months
before her hallucinations started going
away
um so it's variable but uh but those are
kind of the averages that I see for
somebody in that state that sounds like
a very long time because every day is a
very long time but uh in the greater
scheme of things
that's not very long especially given
you're supposed to try a medication out
for like six weeks right at minimum
so
yeah okay I mean then to the time course
yeah the time course said it takes to
respond to the ketogenic diet is similar
to the time course that it takes to
respond to medications
antipsychotic meds almost never even
begin to work even if they work for
people they almost never begin to work
until about six to eight you know well
about four to six weeks in
but that's only beginning and then like
the three months the four month Mark is
where you start getting the full
benefits is what we usually tell people
in Psychiatry and so in a way the
ketogenic diet is nothing different it's
um but it's using very different
strategy
that I believe has enormous
long-term upside potential for actually
healing the brain and healing the person
even allowing them to get off meds and
then again live happily ever after fully
recover
whereas the medications that we're
prescribing
you know I know you experience this
and
I've seen many patients who experience
this in the long-term longitudinal
studies suggests that this might be
happening
when people are on meds long term they
tend to have chronic disorders meaning
that their symptoms never go away
the symptoms will come and go sometimes
they'll get worse sometimes the symptoms
will progressively get worse morph into
new symptoms so somebody could start
with depression now they've got bipolar
now they've got
schizoaffective now they've got
schizophrenia and oh by the way along
the way of that trajectory they're also
developing OCD and panic disorder and
substance use disorders and eating
disorders and sleep problems and all
sorts of other symptoms
when people can end up with all of these
diagnostic labels
they can become disabled by their
psychiatric disorders
despite getting boatloads of treatment
and
I am really passionate about changing
that our field needs to change and our
field needs to change based on science
not just these anecdotes that I've
shared we we have dozens and dozens of
patients now we have five clinical
trials underway already yes
and so this is
this is about transforming the mental
health field five clinical studies
underway right now yes
actually even more than that because
there are five clinical trials underway
for bipolar disorder and schizophrenia
there are additional clinical trials
that I am also aware of for alcoholism
for post-traumatic stress disorder for
depression
um
and
those are the ones that come to me I
thought my head Alzheimer's disease
certainly uh and and you know we've got
a robust evidence based already in
epilepsy wow
yay okay that's great
well I I feel like once there are a
number of studies people can start
quoting out there this whole industry is
going to change rather rapidly because
doctors are trying to help people and
they don't have the tools right now that
would help a lot of people I think it'll
change fast what do you think how fast
do you think it'll take
the world to take the ketogenic diet
seriously as a way of treating
depression and mental disorders
so
if you look at the
if you look at the usual trajectory of
implementation of an evidence-based
treatment
on average
when researchers publish a study
that strongly
suggests or proves that a treatment
works even if that treatment works
really well
on average it is 17 years
before that treatment is recommended to
people in clinical practice
I have reason
to fear that that will not happen with
the ketogenic diet
and the reason I have reason to fear
that is for a few reasons one is we have
dozens and dozens of clinical randomized
controlled trials published in the best
medical journals available of the
ketogenic diet for weight loss
and yet
and there's clinical trials show the
ketogenic diet is almost always
equal to
if not Superior to
a low-fat diet or calorie restricted
diet or some other diet
and yet the majority of clinical
um you know clinicians will not
recommend the ketogenic diet for weight
loss
likewise we have dozens and dozens of
clinical trials of the ketogenic diet
for type 2 diabetes
and yet the majority of clinicians will
not recommend low carbohydrate or
ketogenic diets for their patients with
type 2 diabetes
we have had Century of research a
ketogenic diet for epilepsy and the
majority of people we have two chakran
reviews which are the gold standard of
evidence in the medical field and the
majority of people with treatment
resistant epilepsy are not even told
about this treatment option
so I decided long ago about five years
ago
I
you know my scientific path went
ketogenic diet for serious mental
illness
I began collaborating with researchers
around the world
we've had several case reports and case
series we've had small
clinical trials published some that I've
participated in some other researchers
have done completely independent of me
all suggesting the same results
we have had numerous scientific articles
outlining the Neuroscience of the
ketogenic diet and why this should be
taken seriously for people with mental
illness or serious mental disorders
and uh and those have been published in
some of the leading neuroscience and
psychiatric journals Again by Leading
psychiatrists and neuroscientists
um
so
I went that way but I went much much
deeper and because at the end of the day
schizophrenia is not supposed to go into
remission
according according to the current
psychiatric Dogma once you're
schizophrenic you're schizophrenic for
life
and once you're bipolar you're bipolar
for life
and you certainly have to take
medications for the rest of your life
and there's there there's no ifs ands or
buts about them that is fact according
to the most psychiatrists
and what I was seeing is I was seeing
people get fully better off their meds
and going on to live happy healthy lives
sometimes for years or decades and I was
like this says that what we are telling
people in Psychiatry cannot be 100 true
because I'm seeing all of these
exceptions to the rule right in front of
me there's no way in hell this can be
true
and so I was more intrigued with what
can we learn
what can we learn from these cases that
might help us better understand mental
illness
that is and now so now I'm way Beyond
ketogenic diet as a treatment I'm 100 in
support of it I'm not never abandoning
it I'm never leaving it behind that I'm
moving on from ketogenic diet as a
treatment now I'm go I'm pursuing
what causes mental illness yeah yeah and
how does it how does it make sense that
a diet
could change it
and how does it make sense that some of
the meds that we prescribe
pause weight gain
yeah they cause diabetes
and yet in clinical trials they
supposedly reduce the symptoms of these
illnesses
and how can I as an academic
psychiatrist make sense of that
and that is
ultimately the path that I've been on
for about five or six years
and that's what led to me writing this
book Brain energy that it really
outlines the metabolic theory of mental
illness
and what I'm arguing is that mental
disorders are metabolic disorders
to get back to your question like when
are we really going to see this
implemented in real life
I decided five years ago
the field of Psychiatry is not going to
change on its own
the field of Psychiatry is not going
to go down
without a fight because the field is
based on billion dollar Pharmaceuticals
the field is based on hospitalizations
and whole systems of care
and this new way of understanding mental
illness will be highly disruptive and
you know that's a business term
disruption the personal computers
disrupted the typewriter industry
if you were in the typewriter industry
you didn't want to hear about personal
computers and you didn't want to talk
about them and you did everything you
could to squash them
because they're going to put you out of
business
my belief is that the metabolic theory
of mental illness will be highly
disruptive in the mental health field
and
I am hoping to start a Grassroots
movement
I think the only way we will get change
the only way we will help other people
suffering from chronic depression
anxiety bipolar disorder schizophrenia
help them fully recover
and the ways that both you and your
father have
is through a Grassroots movement
um but it's got to be a Grassroots
movement based on science based on
evidence based on putting it all
together so that we can understand
very clearly
how exactly
do these medications work why would they
reduce symptoms in the short run but
also why should we be terrified about
what we might be doing to people in the
long run with these very medications
your story is not unusual
I felt better for a year
and then everything started falling
apart
and then more symptoms more side effects
more and more pills
and your story is not unusual your story
is actually a hell of a lot more common
than most people realize
and we need to change that but we're
going to need people we are going to
need people to get upset about this
why would they get upset
because either they're suffering from a
mental disorder themselves they're
trapped in this system right now or they
have a loved one they have a son or
daughter or husband or mother or father
they have somebody being tormented by
these symptoms not getting better with
current treatments
and we need all of them to rise up and
start demanding change here here
okay I completely agree I completely
agree when I uh when I first started
using so I didn't know about the
ketogenic diet or the paleo diet or
anything but when I first started
cutting out foods and I went into
remission I was
probably on a ketogenic diet I was
eating a lot of meat and fish and greens
and that was basically it
and that took about three months because
I was trying to get the arthritis under
control and that took about three months
and one day my depression went from
being depressed to not depressed and it
happened in a day about three months in
and I was like what even is this reality
that I've never experienced before it
was so different that it was
mind-boggling and I was ecstatic and
then
I went off of my medication too quickly
I just stopped taking them I was like
I've stopped taking the immune
suppressants I stopped taking
um the pills I was taking at night for
pain I stopped taking everything stopped
taking Adderall for fatigue and all that
was fine and then I stopped taking the
SSRI and like my entire life fell apart
again
and I was like how is this possible so
you you looking into why this works is
extremely interesting because I don't
think anyone wow how about instead of
that what have you found out about why
the ketogenic diet or being in ketosis
helps mental disorders so at the end of
the day the quick version is that I have
come to the scientific conclusion
not based on speculation not me making
up some cockeyed Theory
I looked at all of the existing evidence
and that's all I used
I looked at all of the existing evidence
decades and Decades of clinical evidence
Neuroscience research genetic research
Metabolic Research so research on
Obesity and diabetes and but
neurological research as well research
on epilepsy and Alzheimer's disease
because initially I was
just completely perplexed like why the
hell would a epilepsy treatment work for
Psychiatry but actually it's not just
the keto diet it's all these meds like
we've got dozens of anti-epilepsy so I
knew that I had to go there I knew I had
to go all of it
at the end of the day when you put all
of that research together
there is one and only one conclusion and
that is that mental disorders are
metabolic disorders of the brain
in order to understand what that means
you know a lot of people think of
metabolism as burning calories
and it's related to your diet
and that affects your weight so
metabolism is all about diet and burning
calories and your weight
in fact yeah metabolism is definitely
related to those three things but it is
so so much more than that
metabolism is a fundamental biological
process that is actually fundamental to
all living organisms and it's actually
part of the definition of what we call
living organisms so you have to
understand this overwhelmingly complex
thing that we call metabolism
and at first it's overwhelming and it's
complex
but if you kind of ask some basic
questions like well what controls
metabolism
then you actually LED these tiny things
in all of our cells called mitochondria
and when I did a deep dive into the
science of mitochondria
that's when my mind was blown
because that's when I could connect all
of the dots of the mental health field
is exciting the mitochondria play a role
in neurotransmitters like serotonin and
dopamine mitochondria play a role in
hormone production and regulation like
cortisol and estrogen and testosterone
mitochondria Pern inflammation both on
and off and play a direct role in immune
system function
mitochondria actually are the primary
Regulators of gene expression in the
cell nucleus and I could keep going on
but when you do this deep dive of
science into mitochondria and you
understand all of their roles
and then you ask basic Common Sense
questions like well what would happen if
mitochondria weren't functioning
properly
you actually can begin to understand the
whole mental health field all of the
science
why people with mental diagnoses also
have physical problems like autoimmune
disorders
um chronic pain you know migraine
headaches
fibromyalgia chronic fatigue syndrome
all sorts of other they're actually 50
at least 50 different physical medical
diagnoses that occur much more commonly
in people who also have mental disorders
and what I'm saying is that they're not
all unique the Common Thread among all
of them is metabolism and more
specifically mitochondria
and once you understand that you can
kind of see the big picture
you can understand what's going on but
much much more importantly we can start
implementing
treatments that will heal people like
the ketogenic diet that's fascinating
that's so interesting
okay
um have have you had patients that go on
a ketogenic diet and still have food
sensitivities so they still need to
identify
problematic Foods on the diet
and it yeah
yeah
well I was just going to say does that
seem to happen more to people who are
sicker
or do you not see a correlation
I think I do see a correlation the
people who have extreme food
sensitivities
um and the way I think of food
sensitivity is kind of like an allergy
um so it's you're sensitive to a food
that causes
kind of inflammation somewhere usually
in your gut
and then that can lead to kind of a
permeable gut or a leaky gut
um but it's basically an inflamed God
and the gut is actually really the gut
is an endocrine organ a lot of people
don't realize that but you're the the
cells that line your gut you're actually
secreting all sorts of hormones and
neuropeptides that play a profound role
in metabolism
and when they when those cells become
inflamed that means that your hormone
system
is off balance now and and that can
cause all sorts of problems I think
everybody's heard about the gut brain
connection so the gut is communicating
with the brain
but it's
you know a lot of people want to focus
on just one thing they want to say so so
Roger Palmer what you're really saying
is it's all inflammation right I'm like
no that's not what I'm saying Dr Palmer
what you're really saying it's all it's
all the gut it's all leaky gut I'm like
nope that's not what I'm saying either
but yes inflammation is part of it yes
leaky gut is part of it for some people
but but there can be people who have
metabolic problems primarily because of
trauma and abuse
we know so we know so that's that is the
thing that got me the most excited about
this theory is that it connects
biological with psychological and social
stressors
and we know that psychological and
social stressors play a role in mental
illness
and interestingly they also play a role
in metabolic disorders too so people who
have really horrible childhoods lots of
abuse
and other adversity in life they are
more likely to have mental disorders
that's not surprising most people but
it's across the board mental disorders
it's not just PTSD
they're also more likely to have
depression and personality disorders and
anxiety disorders and alcoholism and
heroin addiction and suicidality but
also guess what they're also more likely
to have bipolar disorder and
schizophrenia all pretty much all of the
mental disorders other than maybe the
neurodevelopmental disorders which those
either occur when you're developing or
not
um
but on top of that they're also more
likely to have obesity diabetes
premature cardiovascular disease and
they're much more likely to die early
deaths
wow
that's that's a bit I mean if you think
about it I guess intuitively
then yeah you can see how that makes
sense especially if you think of an
animal an abused animal then that animal
is going to grow up and be sickly you
could like you can kind of understand
that but I was always taught that uh any
type of depression at least that ran in
my family was because of a chemical
imbalance right like and it was just
that and then I've had people come to me
and they're like well you had an
autoimmune disorder like maybe that
contributed to the depression and was
like at that point I was like no it's a
chemical imbalance this is before the
whole diet thing happened but um that's
nuts so what do you think happens to
people
you know on a more biological level what
happens to people when they suffer from
abuse how does that contribute to health
issues later so the the the quick answer
is that abuse
leads to
a a
tightened stress response or
self-defense response so your your body
ends up
kind of allocating a lot of your
metabolic resources like even just
glucose and fatty acids and other
metabolic resources to your fight or
flight system and why is it doing that
because your life is threatened or at
least you think your life is threatened
so if you're
if you've got somebody beating the [ __ ]
out of you or raping you or other things
you should feel like your life is
threatened because it in fact it is
threatened
and so you are gonna go into this hyper
fight or flight mode
that is not a disorder that is your body
fighting for its survival your body is
saying alert read alert like somebody is
trying to kill me and take my life
and what but what that means is that all
of like any kind of rest and repair
activity that your body should be going
undergoing is put on hold
so good sleep is now off the table you
should not be sleeping well if somebody
is beating you up on a regular basis why
because because they might sneak into
your room at night and try to bash your
head in you should not be sound asleep
you should wake up when you even hear
that somebody touching the doorknob you
hear somebody touching the doorknob you
should be awake so you can try to defend
yourself or run or at least like put
your arms up or whatever to try to save
your life
but if you're not sleeping soundly it
means that your body is falling into a
state of disrepair
it's using all of its energy and
resources for defense for self-defense
and it's not spending the resources on
maintenance and repair and growth and
health
and
if that occurs over a long period of
time those people will slowly but surely
develop metabolic and mental health
problems and it runs the gamut of all
sorts of problems wow
um is it possible that somebody could be
in a stressful situation and like have
these issues sleeping which leads to
Medical metabolic problems and then the
stressful situation goes away but their
body is stressed because of the state
that the stress put them in so then the
metabolic disorder doesn't go away even
though the stressor so that's why
childhood trauma could be an issue even
though you're not experiencing trauma at
the moment you're still suffering from
repercussions wow that's crazy how young
how young can that start how like can
that happen before the age of two and
then it just screws you up forever oh my
gosh yeah so we we know that infants
when infants are maltreated or abused or
neglected
they have an extraordinarily heightened
stress response
um if you see infants yeah if you see
infants who are abused or neglected they
I mean they're screaming
constantly if you look at like the the
most tragic or I shouldn't say the most
but one tragic example of that are
Romanian orphans from you know the 1980s
um a lot of Romanian orphans were put in
orphanages they were never even picked
up
um somebody would just shove a bottle in
their mouth in the crib and like no but
humans didn't even touch them
and
you know when when infants are treated
that way they go through stages of
kind of
adaptations if you will I mean first
they're just screaming bloody murder
because they're trying to get somebody
to pick them up and pay attention to
them
um because their survival depends on it
um
after a while they actually lose the
drive to scream and cry and they
actually become really quiet the
Romanian orphans many of them would
actually start like banging their heads
against the cribs in order to feel
something because nobody was touching
them maybe they would like bang their
heads to the point of bleeding and so
so these so abuse and Trauma
in fact
humans at any point in time
here's so that is all horrible Doom and
Gloom pessimistic [ __ ] I get it here
here's here's the good news here's some
good news folks
in the way that you said what about
years later
somebody who had a really shitty
childhood or experience or just you know
suffered from a rape or a veteran a war
veteran who experienced atrocities in
the battlefield and comes back tormented
with PTSD symptoms if those people
aren't recovering years later I mean
Step One is get the person out of Danger
get the person into a safe environment
give them their basic
requirements food shelter you know a
good safe place to sleep all of those
things but if if you if years later they
still are not recovering
we can use metabolic treatment
strategies to help them recover
that means we can change their diet
sometimes to something like ketogenic
diet or your Lions diet something we can
change their diet try to help their
metabolism heal or repair what we're
really doing is helping their
mitochondria heal and repair
um but we can also use exercise and
stress reduction and other techniques
but it's a lot of common sense lifestyle
techniques and some that aren't common
sense at all again the science of the
ketogenic diet is not common sense to
most people most people don't get it a
lot of people are skeptical about it
but I've outlined all of this science
try to get people to understand it
because I think once people understand
it you will become empowered to do
something about it plus there's just
nothing there's nothing worse than like
watching I think watching one of your
family members or close friends suffer
especially from something like
hey their life is good maybe their life
is great their life is great why are
they I mean you had one patient she's
catatonic what's going on and then
there's so much anger too associated
with like and frustration especially if
the person's relatively normal and then
they fall into that it's like hey you're
a university Professor or you're a
teacher you're in a good relationship
what's wrong with you
and then to see the amount they're
suffering like nothing like hurts like
that it just hurts so much to see
somebody suffering like that so if
there's an option I'd say well it's a
matter of making people believe right
and if you've been through the medical
system for like 15 years and you've
tried everything
at some point it's a lot easier not
being hopeful anymore
like just kill off that hope part of me
because I can't keep having this hope
and then Soul crushing you know failure
of whatever I've tried so it's just a
matter of I guess getting people hopeful
again and again I I am set on not just
blind belief that's why I went the path
I went because I kind of knew nobody's
gonna take me seriously I'm seeing these
miracle cures from the ketogenic diet
and I know that nobody's going to take
them seriously it doesn't it doesn't
matter that I'm a Harvard Professor
nobody gives a [ __ ] they're just gonna
think I'm a Harvard Professor who went
crazy
and and that's and that's it that's all
they're gonna think and they're not
gonna listen they're not gonna take this
seriously
and so I recognized I have to go far
beyond the ketogenic diet I have to
explain the science of this
I never in my wildest dreams set out to
kind of create
what appears to be a unifying theory for
all mental illness that actually
integrates the biological psychological
and social factors into one thing that
was never my goal I kind of just
stumbled upon it somehow I don't know
how and it's kind of like mind-blowing
like oh my God what on Earth just
happened and
um
but I am hoping
that it once people understand the
science
of this new Theory
they're gonna see whoa this you like
this is connecting an awful lot of dots
and then I mean even at people who've
like read the book and start to
understand the theory they're like I
started fact checking you because I was
like mind blown myself and I'm like this
can't possibly be true so I'm Googling
all of these things and even Googling
things that you haven't included and
[ __ ] you're right oh my God like like
this is real some people need to take
this seriously and but once you
understand it
then you can have hope and it's real
hope based on real solutions and
practical Solutions so I am no way
I'm not saying the ketogenic diet is
going to cure everyone because I think
if you're a chronic alcoholic
you got to stop drinking the alcohol
that's that's part of your treatment
plan and ketogenic diet or not is not
going to save you from chronic
alcoholism stopping alcohol is going to
be your first step in Saving you from
chronic alcoholism
but then if you're not fully recovered
after you stop drinking then maybe you
can use diet or exercise or sleep or
stress reduction or light exposure or
lots of other things to heal your body
and your brain
very cool what would your advice be for
someone who wants to stop their
medications and try diet is there an
order in which to do that how do you do
that so I am going to strongly recommend
that you number one please don't stop
your meds on your own cold turkey that
yeah the way that you just described it
can be a nightmare
I have seen so many patients
hospitalized or the police get called or
some who end up dead
they they just become overwhelmed with
mental symptoms whether it's depression
or hallucinations or suicidality
and it just seems
I'm assuming you know we don't know
because they're dead but I'm assuming it
just seemed like a good decision to go
ahead and kill themselves and they did
so please don't stop your meds cold
turkey on your own number one not
because I don't want people to get off
their meds because I am desperately
trying to get a lot of people off their
meds but I want to do it in a safe way
that they can tolerate that is you know
safe for everybody involved
um
usually
when I implement the ketogenic diet if
somebody's been stable on their meds for
a while even though they're clearly
having symptoms because they wouldn't be
coming to me if they or if they were
totally fine
they would probably wouldn't be coming
to me so they're usually coming to me
because their things are not okay and
they want to try something different but
if they've been on their meds for a
while I usually don't touch their meds
initially I start the diet
they make sure they can do the diet and
I make sure that we start to see some
benefits from the diet and again that
can be three or four months for some
people
I also want to make sure that the person
can actually do the diet and stick with
it
um because I'm not going to stop start
stopping their meds and have them do a
diet for four days and then like you
know oh I can't do it anymore I like
bread too much
um it's like well that's not gonna work
then so you're not really willing to do
this treatment because
the diet is part of the treatment I
really want to stress that it it is
you're you're treating your brain by
doing the diet
you're you're healing your body and your
brain and so you've got to be committed
to doing it you and and so I want to see
evidence
that you can somehow
do it
um and or you know I never give up on
people it's not like I tell people do
the diet and then go and come back and
see me when you're doing it it I'm
seeing them all along encouraging
offering practical Solutions if they
fall off the wagon it's like no big deal
everybody falls off the wagon don't
don't sweat it like we will get you back
on the wagon but
what usually by about
four to six months if I'm seeing
significant Improvement in symptoms it
does not at all have to be remission of
symptoms
because unfortunately
I think as you know the medications can
cause symptoms and some people or even a
lot of people and so the full recovery
is let's start the diet
and then we're going to start tapering
meds and we're going to do that in a
safe controlled way that you can
tolerate and your body and brain are
going to tell us how tolerable It Is
we're going to do that
but along the way I'm going to add other
things so I'm going to look at other
substances that they might be using that
might be causing problems and we might
be getting rid of those substances I'm
going to look at sleep and make sure
people are getting good restful sleep
might look at light exposure like avoid
screens in the middle of the night uh
get some bright light in the morning
maybe we're going to look at exercise
get started on an exercise routine if
you're not doing that already so we're
going to look at a comprehensive
treatment plan
all of those things are common sense you
all yeah
many of your listeners already know them
so they already know all that stuff so
it's not rocket science it's I'm not
Reinventing anything these are just good
practical Common Sense human health
things that all humans benefit from
doing
and slowly but surely we try to get
people off their meds
and usually once they're off all their
meds and they're doing these things
that's when
I see dramatic full lasting recoveries
and then actually people have to go
through a grieving period usually too
if they've been sick for a long time
they get really really sad or really
really angry it's so much that so much
of their life is wasted
yeah nobody told
yeah and that nobody told them this
yeah I like I'm still
well it's frustrating right you don't
get that back
it's crazy
oh no I cried again damn it that's like
my that's my second episode these these
psychiatric these episodes that have
anything to do with like
mental health oh my gosh they get me but
yeah no it's it's heartbreaking and some
people are stuck like that their entire
lives
that's so messed up
that's so messed up
it is messed up and we need to change
this and we need help we need help we
need everybody to help yeah
do you do you get a
do you get any negative feedback from
professors at Harvard or any of your
colleagues
honestly I get asked that a lot
and so far
shockingly
the answer is not yet I'm waiting for it
I think they're hoping that's great I
think they're hoping this is all going
to go away
yeah Chris Palmer Chris Palmer and his
little book are just gonna disappear
into Oblivion and nobody's really going
to pay attention and nobody's gonna know
any of this
and we'll just go on with the status quo
but
again like
so I've
I've gotten some of the leading
psychiatrist and neuroscientists to
publicly endorse this book in this
Theory they you go to Amazon and they're
right there
they're in the book they've read the
book and they've endorsed it
so
that is important because it says that
I'm not 100 crazy
people want to think I'm crazy if people
think I've gone too far if people think
you know you can't disrupt a whole field
Chris Palmer who the hell do you think
you are and I know there are lots of
people who are probably thinking that
um
I know that I'm not completely crazy
because I provided enough solid
scientific evidence
I think if this really starts to become
disruptive
that's when I will get pushed back
um and it will likely come
from the
forces that have
billion dollar products to lose and I
can't blame them if I had a billion
dollar drug I would be pissed at Chris
Palmer who the hell does he think he is
coming along disrupting my billion
dollar drug
um this is my money and I'm a
billionaire and I'm happy and don't
don't you come along with some new
Theory and convince people to get off my
drug like you know F you Chris Palmer
and they will and they will send their
experts it won't be the drug company
coming after me it will be experts in
Psychiatry and the Neuroscience field
who will come after me yeah and they
will be Hired Guns by these companies
and they will be hired with one primary
purpose discredit Chris Palmer and this
Theory this is becoming a threat to our
business and our shareholders and they
will start attacking me and either on a
personal level or a professional level
for any level
and I'm I'm sort of ready for them I
mean I in preparing this Theory and this
book
I was meticulous about lining up my
defenses and lining up my arguments I
mean I realized people are gonna attack
this this is crazy I need to think
through every detail and at least kind
of
line up some arguments
the really great promising news is that
you know I work at McLean Hospital it's
a Harvard Hospital we're actually
currently ranked the number one
psychiatric hospital by U.S news and
World Report
the president of the hospital my boss
the chief academic officer
the board the chairwoman of the Board of
Trustees they all know about me and are
all supporting me right now
so I
feel
kind of privilege to work at the
hospital I've worked at where they are
they're not publicly backing this that's
not their job
but they also aren't interfering with my
ability to talk about it that's more
present it it they they kind of I think
see it as we are an academic center and
academic centers allow for scientific
discussion and discourse and we if
you've got a theory and you want to
present it that's what that's what we do
that's what academic psychiatrists and
you know academics do is they present
ideas they present new theories
and go do it like we're not saying we
agree with you but we're also not saying
we disagree with you you're one of us so
we're going to support your right to do
that good and I think that's where I'm
at so
but again I decided a long time ago I'm
not taking this to the psychiatric
professionals because they won't they
won't buy it they'll shoot it down
because it's too disruptive so I decided
to take this to the people and let the
people vote and let the people decide
that was wise
and obviously it's working you've been
on a ton of different podcasts yeah the
book and I've had people who weren't
interested in diet at all say oh have
you heard of Chris Palmer like brain
energy it's like yeah definitely
Harvard's talking about diet yeah yeah
it's really awesome people who like
aren't interested you know because it's
kind of easy I think once you're in the
Paleo Community or keto Community or
that kind of community then if somebody
pops up you kind of hear about them but
I've definitely heard about you through
people who are in like CrossFit and
don't necessarily think that what you
eat matters
they're like oh well Chris Palmer though
said maybe it does matter it's like yeah
pretty cool yeah and you're like yeah
I've been saying that for years where
the hell have you been now you're gonna
listen
um or maybe a little maybe a little bit
to certain people but no I'm happy about
this it was great okay well I've got one
I want to stick in here that was just I
was just interested to get to get your
opinion on or do you have an opinion on
this new
semi-glutide drug that celebrities seem
to be taking to lose weight yeah I know
semic blue tide is like it is
it is in demand and you it's actually
there's a shortage of it nationally it
can be hard to get it approved
you know the the early results right now
suggest that
semi-glutide is highly effective for
weight loss it's really a diabetes it
was developed as a diabetes drug
and uh and then they quickly noticed
that a lot of people with diabetes were
losing significant amounts of weight so
now it is also a weight loss drug or
it's becoming a weight loss drug
um I do have one patient who's on it and
just increased his dose and is actually
losing more weight and his blood sugars
are coming down even more even though he
has been on a ketogenic diet for a long
time he's been on a ketogenic diet for a
long time and it was in and of itself
was not enough
but that's where I feel like you know
there's more to health and metabolic
health and mental health than just the
diet you have to have good sleep
we just found out he's got horrible
sleep apnea
um and that was never addressed
um and you've got to decrease stress and
you've got to manage other substances
and prescription meds and he's on
several and so it's really a combination
of all of those things
um you know if you you're a perfect
example if you had stayed on all of your
meds
and the diet there's a chance the meds
may have prevented you from having a
full and complete recovery
and um and so I think I think it is the
combination of different strategies
um that are effective but
I think my you know so for people who
need to lose weight can somebody glue
tied be helpful yes you can
do I think it is really the full answer
for all of our health problems
absolutely not
there is a reason we have an obesity
epidemic
it probably relates to the foods we're
eating and or environmental toxins or
something about our lifestyle
everybody's on their phone and said like
whatever it is everybody's and a lot of
people like focus on one and only one of
those things and so it's all that that's
what it is it's fine they could have
their opinion I actually think it's
probably a lot of those things so it's a
combination of all the chemicals and
other stuff in our diet and the way our
foods have changed and they're super
high in carbohydrates and we went
through this whole low fat thing and
we're now going to this hole everybody
should eat only plants and avoid meat
and that's I don't see that as
necessarily being a path to health
um so we've got lots of problems with
diet
but the environmental toxins if you
really do a deep dive into those those
don't look pretty either
oh yeah they're probably not helping us
um
and semi-glutide isn't removing any of
those factors
semi-glutide is just helping people lose
some weight
but if you're still exposing yourself to
a toxic diet if you're not changing what
you're eating
you're still exposing yourself to
whatever it is whether for the people
who think it's all carbs fine for the
people who think it's plant-based Foods
fun for the people who think it's animal
sourced Foods it doesn't matter I I
don't pick pick whatever part of the
diet you hate
taking a pill doesn't necessarily change
your diet it doesn't necessarily mean
you're eating less of those toxic food
sources
and and so I'm worried that we might be
getting some short-term weight loss
maybe for several years even
but that over time we're going to see
the exact same thing that we have seen
with
gastric bypass surgery
gastric bypass surgery works wonders
there is no question about it people
lose massive amounts of weight
in the first couple of years
but if they don't change anything else
the weight starts coming back an owl
broker is like a poster person and very
public about his experience with that
for that and he then finally found the
ketogenic diet
to definitively put his weight under
control
but
so I'm worried that stomach glue tide is
going to be the same deal that yeah
everybody's all psyched about it right
now just like they were about gastric
bypass surgery but if we don't address
the root problem
the problem's gonna come back I can get
behind that
I can get beyond that um do you do you
get concerns from patients or how would
you address the concerns about the
ketogenic diet impacting cardiac health
negatively so the the longitudinal
studies that we've got and we've got
plenty
we have dozens and dozens
of weight loss trials
trials for people with type 2 diabetes
of low carb and or ketogenic diets
in the overwhelming majority of those
studies
show that if you do a comprehensive
cardiovascular risk assessment
cardiovascular risk goes down with the
ketogenic diet
that means
HDL levels improve go a little bit
higher
triglycerides usually plummet that's
good thing blood pressure usually comes
down very nicely that's a great thing
uh people lose a lot of weight that's a
great thing levels of inflammation come
down that's a great thing
the thing that of course the
cardiologists focus on is but LDL goes
up sometimes well LDL is one of many
biomarkers that plays a role in
cardiovascular disease if you believe
that LDL cholesterol is directly linked
and is I think you and many of your
listeners know that is controversial and
uh and some people don't believe that
and some people don't believe the
evidence base for that
I don't even need to go there even for
somebody who is tried and true no LDL
really does play a role in
cardiovascular disease even if you
really firmly are 100 convinced of that
cardiovascular risk still goes down with
ketogenic diet and I mean the virtus
study cool you know has been going on
for over five years ketogenic diet for
people with type 2 diabetes high risk
for heart attacks
overall their risk has gone down nice I
like how this can be in the scientific
literature it's so much easier than
being like well it worked for me
argument it unfortunately yeah we that's
I think that's one of the things I bring
to the keto low carb Community is I'm
like focused on science and like and I'm
I'm almost like a lawyer too I'm like
how am I gonna defend this like I I
already know what the opposition is
going to say and how they're going to
attack me so what how can I line up some
science to defend this position
and I think these are 100 defensible
positions in the mental health field
make no mistake
we prescribe medications that cause
people to gain massive amounts of weight
we prescribe medications that cause type
2 diabetes we prescribe medications that
cause heart attacks it's right on the
package insert from not being paranoid
or conspiracy theorists by saying this
we prescribe medications that cause be
mature death read the package inserts
it's right there
the ketogenic diet helps people lose
weight get rid of their diabetes or
improve their insulin sensitivity lower
their risks for cardiovascular disease
make them feel a hell of a lot better
helps them get off of medications helps
them start functioning in life again
I really don't give a [ __ ] if their LDL
goes up a little I just don't
[ __ ] and anybody who is going to get
worked up about their LDL going up a
little bit in the context of all of that
other stuff is an absolute positive
idiot and they are inhumane they are
inhumane that they would let people
suffer and writhe in mental pain and be
disabled by their illness and not offer
them an effective treatment that is just
inhumane you can tell I'm a little
worked up right I'm so sorry I'm worked
up I completely agree I'm worked up I
know like what about I get that all the
time too what about the long-term Health
impacts like the short-term health
impact was I was gonna die so if the
long hard term health impact is I'm
happy for quite a while I like
yes you're alive you're alive and
thriving and not not tormented by
symptoms and not disabled by symptoms
and yeah who cares who
do I want research to really answer
these questions yes I do want research
yeah me too because because if I could
tweak your diet somehow to give you even
more of an edge I would love to know
that and I would love to know to just be
able to give you the information like if
you do this version of the Lion's diet
you're gonna have these kind of outcomes
if you if we can tweak these biomarkers
you might even get better results or
live longer or yes I would love that
information
but again we need a Grassroots movement
to get funding for those studies because
the powers that be are not going to fund
those studies right now this is very
true okay I think I have one question
based off what you were just talking
about
um you said we prescribe medications
that cause some of these side effects
because they're listed on the bottle
um one of the so I was put on
antidepressants when I was 12 so I
didn't understand the difference between
the depression and what a side effect
was I just thought everything I
experienced was a new health problem
which wasn't how it was in reality a lot
of them were side effects but one of the
side effects I think I had was I was
never full at all I was absolutely
starving all the time uh in a way that
I'd go out for dinner and I'd feel
physically full like unbuttoning My
Pants full and I can remember being so
hungry that I'd have to be like okay
take the food away or I'll keep eating
it like just no control and I am a very
self-disciplined person so it wasn't
because of that um have you do you think
the weight gain Associated that can be
associated with SS or I use
is because people get hungrier or do you
think it's something else I think
it can I think that it can
be different mechanisms of action and
again we don't really have good robust
science to answer that exact question
the thing that we do have good robust
science on is a lot of people on ssris
gain massive amounts of weight
um or at least a little bit of weight
that is not controversial that is not
anecdotal you know one of the ways they
attack all of this is oh it's just an
anecdote that's not an anecdote people a
lot of people gain weight not everybody
does and some people go on ssris and
they swear that their life is much
better and that's great I'm not here to
take that away from them I'm not here to
stand in their way they can keep taking
their SSRI or other psychiatric
medications I'm not here to take any of
that away I'm here to empower people
with other options with other treatment
strategies if what you're doing isn't
working
I'm here to do that the SSRI the ssris
we have strong reason to believe like 90
95 of the serotonin in the human body is
actually found in the digestive tract
so serotonin is regulating appetite and
feeding behaviors and nutrient kind of
sensing throughout the body and it does
this actually in a whole range of
species all the way down to like worms
and stuff worms have serotonin that it's
regulating their whole body metabolism
so we know that serotonin is regulating
whole body metabolism in humans
and or at least playing a role in it and
when you take a pill
that is causing massive shifts in
serotonin levels
all the way down to the synapse
it shouldn't be shocking to anyone that
that might disregulate
normal metabolic controls which include
hunger which include feeding behaviors
but also include metabolism broadly
so some so I think for some people it
can be exactly what you describe I
become ravenous I can't read this crazy
and I think for some people it is that
there's no doubt in my mind I have
talked to other people who are highly
trustworthy
Dependable responsible disciplined
people who swear to me I am not eating
more calories I swear to you I'm not and
yet I'm gaining weight
and I believe them I believe they are
not eating more calories I don't think
they're lying to me I don't think
they're fooling themselves I don't think
it's subconscious I don't think they're
just not tracking their calories I
believe them I think they're telling me
the truth and in that case I think the
medication is probably plummeting their
metabolism their metabolic rate so that
they are burning fewer calories so that
even if they're still eating the same
1500 or 2 000 calories a day that
they're burning it less efficiently and
that means more calories to store is
that that's crazy
it is crazy
wow like for me I think I mean maybe
both could have been going on I know I I
started eating less and less it took a
while too after I stopped taking
medication I was eating tons of food and
losing weight on the like keto paleo
diet and then when I switched over to a
carnivore diet I was eating tons of food
and losing weight initially although
then I was overeating and I started
gaining weight which is normal like if
you're eating 2 400 calories a day and
you're me you should be slowly gaining
weight and that was because my appetite
still hadn't
normalized I was still hungry and then
at some point I think it was kind of
like eight months into the diet I was
like oh you know two-thirds of my Hunger
is gone suddenly like okay that's handy
that's great so
it's weird it's weird out there I really
really appreciate what you're doing I
think you're on to something I don't
think you're gonna be crushed because it
works too well so there is no crushing
it and one person whose life you change
uh will tell like uh 200 people about it
for the next five years
or the rest of their life because it's
it's so crazy to go from the I'm [ __ ]
forever
and nothing will help me and I've tried
everything to I'm healthy in maybe what
six weeks like no that that's that's a
show that's short but even three or four
months or just the possibility of that
happening changes people's lives so I
don't think there's any crushing it it
works too well you can't Crush that yeah
no I agree I agree now I want to spread
it I want this offered to people when
they get
involuntarily hospitalized yeah instead
of ice cream here's some ice cream
that's gonna help you feel better I'm
involuntarily hospitalized ice cream
doesn't help it just makes like
everything work it's crazy what they
feed people in there it is it is done
foundingly
sad it's just sad looking at what they
get I mean it's almost
all carbohydrates
and
um you know pancakes for breakfast or
just a box of cereal with some milk and
uh
yeah mac and cheese
and other things and ice cream and
cookies and brownies
and
yeah I want these treatments in place of
medications at some point you know and
not for the dangerous situations for
people who are about to assault someone
or kill themselves yes I think that some
of our standard treatments are still
going to be required because they are a
danger to themselves or others and we
have to keep them safe
but
you know right now none of this is being
offered to anybody it's not being
offered on an inpatient unit it's not
being offered on an outpatient basis
it's not being offered to anyone and
when they hear you or me talk about it
they're laughed at
for you know what crazy person are you
listening to
and that is what I'm hoping
that's what I'm hoping the book can
change is it just provides tons of
scientific evidence
it's a science book and I kind of want
to apologize for that and not apologize
for because it's kind of like if you
hate science I'm really sorry you're
gonna feel like why the hell is he
talking about all this stuffing science
um but I did it because I want people to
take these treatments seriously and I
want to give people hope and Empower
them well
thank you
if people don't follow you online where
can they go now and definitely check out
the book Brain energy it's probably
available everywhere and if you have a
relative or something that's skeptical
of diet it might be a way for if I it
might be able to help you back up the
diet argument I've been going on about
diet for years here's a Harvard Doctor
Who can explain why it works check it
out anyway where are you on social media
the easiest place for people to find me
is either one of two websites so either
brain energy.com
um which has information about the book
and lots of podcasts and articles and uh
we've got a newsletter and we really are
hoping to start a Grassroots movement so
if you want to be involved in this and
create change please go there and at
least sign up let us know about you and
let us know you want to be involved
for people who are interested in more of
some of the detailed research that I've
done on the ketogenic diet
um in both lay press and or academic
articles or more about clinical practice
and stuff they can find me at Chris
palmermd.com great thank you very much
for coming on thank you Michael for
having me
[Music]